christopher nolan's movies often require
a repeat screening or two to fully
process all the plot layers and subtle
details an inception is no different the
2010 film which thrusts its lead
characters into a chemically induced
dream state where they attempt to
implant ideas into people's minds was so
complex and ambiguous that the directors
true meaning has become a point of
cinematic controversy don't worry though
we've got your back
let's dive into explaining the ending of
Inception grief and guilt at its core
inception is about two things grief and
guilt Leonardo DiCaprio's Cobb is
working to get back to his children
after his wife mal committed suicide
which looks more like Cobb himself
killed her
at least that's how he remembers it but
his memories are clouded by guilt over
his role in her death after an
experiment gone wrong which trapped
Malin Cobb together for what seemed like
decades in limbo mal became so absorbed
into the dream world that she could no
longer tell the difference between the
different layers of existence in her
mind the waking world was just another
layer she needed to kick herself out of
so when she leapt from a high-rise hotel
she didn't think she'd actually kill
herself
Cobb feels so responsible for Mal's
death that he keeps his sharpest
memories of her locked away in his mind
but when his protege Ariadne releases
mind mal into the dream she becomes his
biggest obstacle in completing his
Inception mission for mr. Saito she
creeps into the third layer of the group
mission and sends their target Robert
Fisher into limbo Cobb eventually
realizes mine mal is just a projection
of his guilt and grief and lets Ariadne
kill her that theme of getting through a
difficult loss like this plays out on a
parallel plane with Robert Fisher as
he's basically guided through the five
stages of grief amid the looming death
of his death in the end Cobb decides to
embrace the reality he's currently in
with his children in doing so he also
lets go of his guilt and grief it's
probably no coincidence that Nolan lost
his own father in 2009 suggesting that
Inception may just be his most personal
film ever Chris's
very expressive and what he's trying to
accomplish but it is insulated in his
own mind so we knew that we had to take
a leap of faith that darn top
the biggest question viewers have after
seeing inception is this will the
spinning top at the end ever fall down
the top was a totem Kabat created to
show whether or not he was in a dream or
in true reality in a dream it would spin
forever but in the real world it would
eventually fall over for Nolan though
the whole point of that ending is that
it doesn't matter to Cobb anymore
whether he's in a dream world or the
real world which is why he doesn't
bother waiting to find out the results
of his final spin he's happy to be
reunited with his children and he
decides that this is the reality he
wants to live in regardless of whether
it's a dream or not we all dream until
to the universal experience but a very
private one it's all Greek to us in
creek mythology Ariadne is a young
goddess of the island of Crete who's put
in charge of a labyrinth that sees the
sacrifice of several Athenians each year
but upon finding affection for one of
its would-be victims Theseus
she helps him escape by giving him a red
string and a sword to defeat the
Minotaur and find his way out of the
maze
not only does inception Darion D almost
always wear red but she also slowly but
surely shows Cobb the way to overcome
his own demon the long lingering image
of his dead wife some fans theorize
Ariane D may have originally been hired
by Stephen miles Mao's father to
discover whether Cobb had actually
killed mal or was as innocent as he
claimed that would explain why Ariadne
is so acutely interested in delving into
Cobb and Mal's history after seeing the
toll it takes on him however she may
have developed a fondness or sympathy
for him and decides to help him escape
in the end much like her mythological
namesake daddy issues Cobb and crew have
to sift through a lot of layers to get
to the bottom of Fisher's allegiance to
his father's company but by the end it
becomes clear that all Fisher ever
really wanted was the affection and
respect of his old man that's why when
his dad tells him to open the safe
that's been planted by Cobbs team in his
dreamworld hospital room all it contains
was a pinwheel that reminds Fisher of
one of the few happy memories from his
childhood for Fisher the pinwheel
signifies that his dad treasured him
more than he ever let on which gives
value to a suggestion that Fisher go off
and become his own man and thus dissolve
the company that's causing mr. Sato so
much trouble the eye of the needle while
Sato isn't exactly evil he's willing to
go to some great lengths in order to get
a financial profit for his company
including literally entering someone
else's mind and planting thoughts in it
but Saito's plant backfires
spectacularly when he dies within the
dream and is sent to Limbo Cobb manages
to rescue him but not until Saito has
aged to the point of senility
when they finally emerge from their
dream and back into reality Saito isn't
thrilled about his financial victory but
instead he's rather stoic and seems to
have experienced a change of heart as a
result of his time in limbo with both
Saito and Fisher nolan seems to be
saying there's a lot more to life than
the pursuit of wealth a theme he would
pick up on his next film The Dark Knight
Rises but that's not the only impact
inception would have on Hollywood
inceptions legacy not only did themes of
inception carry over into the Dark
Knight Rises specific character arcs did
too as crazy as that sounds
Joseph gordon-levitt's inception
character Arthur is tasked with keeping
watch over as helpless comrades in much
the same way that his Dark Knight Rises
character Blake protects the innocent
kids of Gotham City Tom Hardy's vein of
meanwhile picks up where his inception
character Eames
leaves off using masks and ultraviolence
to achieve his ends in Merion coach
yards Miranda and mal are each so
devoted to their convictions that they
don't hesitate to sacrifice themselves
for what they believe in the end of
Inception didn't just affect Nolan's
movies either raking in over eight
hundred and twenty five million dollars
worldwide while also garnering massive
critical acclaim inception paved the way
for a whole wave of high concept
big-budget sci-fi fare including films
like looper source-code
The Adjustment Bureau limitless in time
edge of tomorrow
see and then there's Marvel's Doctor
Strange which unapologetically lifted
inceptions entire city bending sequence
however the most obvious and annoying
influence of inception may be this
created by composer Hans Zimmer to give
potency to several action sequences this
obnoxious noise has been featured in
seemingly every sci-fi blockbuster since
inception Zimmer hates it he told
vulture oh it's horrible this is a
perfect example of where it all goes
wrong that music became the blueprint
for all action movies really and if you
get too many imitations even I get
confused so all we can say is enter the
dream ever since inception say beYOU
fans have been clamoring for a sequel
but while nolan has publicly toyed with
the idea of a video game that allows
players to explore the world of
Inception so far nothing has come of it
still there's hope that someday fans may
be able to play through inception
themselves and figure out firsthand just
what the ending means to them thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]